وقد اكد المتحدث باسم حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي طارق سلمي ان اغتيال قاده سرايا
القدس لن يغير شيئا في المعادله فرضتها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه واضاف في مقابله مع
مراسننا في غزه ان المقاومه وسرايا القدس
تملك القوه والقدره على المواجهه وانها
تقود الان ما سماه حربا مفتوحه مع العدو
هذا العدوان ياتي من اجل تغيير المعادله
الا اننا نؤكد في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
بان اغتيال قاده سرايا القدس لن يغير شيء
في المعادله التي فرضتها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالتاكيد الوضع حتى هذه اللحظه
تؤكد حركه الجهاد الاسلامي وسرايا القدس
بانها في حرب مفتوحه مع العدو الصهيوني
وسيدفع ثمن هذه الجرائم وهذه الاغتيالات
التي تمارس على قاده سرايا القدس
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه وشعبنا الفلسطيني
اليوم المقاومه الفلسطينيه مستمره في
القتال والجهاد ضد العدو اغتيال قاده
سرايا القدس واغتيال اعضاء المجلس العسكري
لن يضعف الحركه على العكس يزيد الحركه قوه
واسرار